the reason Taiwan her you about this was
because there were Taiwanese doctors who
had heard from their mainland colleagues
that the medical staff in Wuhan were
getting sick so that's how you know
human-to-human transmission is occurring
it's when you know it's not animal to a
person but person a person it's the
patients are transferring it to to the
doctors so Taiwan reports this and it
takes weeks before you know I think on
the 14th of January you still have that
famous tweet by by the WHL saying
there's still no evidence of human to
human transmission two weeks after
Taiwan told them that was hey i'm dave
rubin and this is the rubin report
reminder everybody you can get all of
our full episodes absolutely ad free
five full days early at rubin report.com
and more importantly joining me today is
the managing director of ideas beyond
borders as well as the new york editor
for Spectator magazine melissa Chen
welcome to the rubin report hi Dave
thank you for having me I cannot believe
that this is your first solo appearance
on the Reuben report you were on the
show way back when when we were on aura
TV that's something like 20 25 years ago
I think at this point with our friend
Faisal armored-car who is who's your
cohort at ideas Beyond Borders yes
there's a ton I want to talk to you
about of course but can you just very
quickly who is Melissa Chen how did did
you get to the ruling report well I have
to thank you for having me on again
because that last time with when I did
it with Basel I had the worst hair
possible I was for some reason
identified as male kpop star and I don't
know what was going on so I'm thankful
to have another chance to show what it
actually can look like potentially so
yes your hair is looking very luxurious
by the way which is hard to do
there's no barbers okay so I'll put that
out there so my name is ELISA and I now
also am a journalist I write for a
spectator which is a British magazine
and I also run a nonprofit organization
called ideas beyond borders together
with faith alone guitar who's a dear
friend of both she and days for a long
time I grew up in Singapore so you know
I only came to the US when I was about
17 came for college loved the experience
of living in a place with so much civil
liberties and you know I guess I stayed
after college I have actually a
background in computational biology that
was my degree and like a good Asian or a
bad Asian I guess I'm not using my
degree and ended up running a non-profit
and and you know writing so that's
that's how I got here yeah all right
very good let's just quickly recap a
little bit about what you guys are doing
with ideas Beyond Borders and then I
want to focus more on what you've been
doing related to coronavirus some
interesting stuff in New York City
trying to get people supplies and and
you have some knowledge on what's going
on with China and the rest of it but
just tell everybody a little bit about
ideas Beyond Borders because before
corona there was a whole other world out
there and you guys were doing some
really great stuff i mean i'd continue
to do right i mean it's interesting
because early you know early January of
2020 the focus of this world was on the
Middle East right right after the whole
general Soleimani was was killed in Iran
him that was shifting the focus to to
that part of the world it seemed like a
hot spot there were protests going on in
Lebanon in Iraq and so you know that
seemed like to be started World War
three or something and all of a sudden
coronavirus just it just consumed
everything so ideas Beyond Borders is a
nonprofit organization founded by my
friend Faisal who's that rocki refugee
and what we do is we take ideas that are
not available in you know Arabic
translate them into the language and
make them freely available we focus on
ideas about science about philosophy in
about civil rights Pro Liberty ideas
basically and the idea is just you know
if you have a head
normative heteronormative sorry Henry
bucks you know if you're exposed to
heterodox idea is that it would
challenge people's minds and it will
open up dogmatic thinking so that was
the reason ideas Beyond Borders was
found it and actually today not only
have we done a ton of books Wikipedia
articles we've also done it was and
right now we're actually combating a lot
of misinformation about coronavirus in
Arabic because ever since China released
that whole propaganda theory about you
know the thing about like the US Army
was the one that released the virus
that's kind of like a theory said take
root in the Arab world that's what the
one belief yeah all right so we're
obviously going to focus a lot on that
but very quickly you mentioned that you
grew up in Singapore till you were 16 17
years old can you talk a little bit
about what that was like and why that
kind of led you to being someone that
actually cares about freedom of
expression and open inquiry and all that
good Liberty stuff that you talk about I
mean Singapore is a great place to grow
up in a way it's very stable very safe
and very affluent of the country very
very high GDP per capita but the one
thing that we didn't have was was
political freedoms so Singapore's ranked
pretty low in terms of freedom of the
press freedom of speech and also you
know very basic things like there's
absolutely no freedom to assemble so if
you decided to go into a public square
and hold a sign that says something like
I don't know impeach the prime minister
or something or even just against the
death penalty you would be arrested
though because you didn't get a permit
for for you for the protest and and
that's the kind of very ordered place a
very ordered society that it has created
but but for me it's always kind of been
this this thing on my shoulder kind of
weighed down on me that you know you
couldn't just speak your mind yet with
the censor and it was just I knew I
wanted to be in a place where where you
know this was just not even I I have to
think about it that you could just be
free be free you know to be yourself
that's all we doing with that in America
Dave you know what still a lot better
but but it's it's it's heartbreaking to
hear and see that we're we're you know
that these freedoms are slowly being
eroded and willingly we're doing it to
ourselves and and it may not be coming
from the government's but but when you
have this kind of mob rule in Kensal
culture it is a de facto censorship and
it it ends up having similar effects on
your psyche on society as a whole and
you know it kind of like bubbles up but
it's still very different I would have
to say you know like there's a
difference between getting disappeared
by your government and getting jailed by
your government for saying the wrong
thing than it is to lose your job but
still yeah for sure
all right so let's let's talk a bit
about Korea and China and some of the
things that you've been doing so first I
want to start you had a tweet thread
recently that you found a donor who
wanted to put a whole bunch of money to
get document under sedation yeah and and
he wanted to put money in so the doctors
and nurses could get masks that's sort
of the short of it and suddenly you
found out that there is a lot of red
tape to make what should be simple
things happen actually happen right
right so you know this what they call
personal protective equipment short of
would be PPE includes masks gowns you
know the face shields and everything
that healthcare workers really need to
use to protect themselves and a lot of
people have been talking about okay you
know what we were in dire need of this
we didn't stock pile a lot of the
hospitals in a stockpile the states
didn't do it and so you know when you
have a sudden rush of cases as you did
in New York City the IC use were or over
capacitated that's when you know
hospitals realize that oh no we're
running out of PPE s very quickly we're
just going through them such quick rate
and and it was a huge shortage and it's
not just in the United States is pretty
much
anywhere else you know italy's facing
the same problem as well so very very
kind donor reached out and said I really
want to help he's not the only one there
are a lot of people that you know I mean
it's one of the best things about
America is it's the ingenuity from from
just average people who just you know
when there's a problem they just step up
and want to just contribute somehow and
so what we started when I started
finding was okay I got I got I got
people saying that Hospital saying you
know we need we need these we need the
TV so badly health care workers the
saying the same thing and then donors
are coming forward but then to even make
that match happen and get the masks to
to the people that need them was a
complete Casca esque nightmare and it's
in part due to all the different layers
of regulation of starting with you know
the the employers basically said if you
if you talk to the press or if you post
them on a social media you might get
fired and i think there was a case where
a doctor in Washington state was fired
for for basically blabbering about the
shortage and then you have the CDC and
the whu-oh saying you know what masks
are not needed right this this was some
rhetoric that's been kind of circulating
since the crisis started and and that
helps hospitals kind of like cya you
know cover your ass because if masks are
not needed then the onus isn't on them
just to stock up and protect the workers
they basically like protect them it
gives them some liability if let's say
you you died on the job or something
then they you know it's harder to sue
because it's not it's not required
right the CDC just say you know don't
really meet masks and then you have
compliance issues so like the FDA you
know they need to certify all the
incoming the the masks for you know does
it do what it says it does and
everything but then different layers of
sort of certification different agencies
have different standards and and then
you have this like war so like all 50
states are bidding the feds are bidding
for the same you know supply pool and
ending of NGOs and then you have a
global market
and and we're all just end up being
bidding against each other just driving
the price up and then it's it's it's you
know what should have been done is like
you know perhaps start off with some
sort of like all the governors kind of
come together they start a consortium
and big right against global actors as
well and it's just there's just so much
redundancy in this built entire market
that it's been so difficult trying to
get ppes to to the hospitals and in the
last yeah I know that a lot of a lot of
my audience a lot of my audience hearing
this is gonna go oh yeah
well of course I mean regulation red
tape this is exactly what the government
does to get us all in a boondoggle where
prices drive up nobody can get what they
want and the rest of it
so would you is the best way to just get
rid of all the red tape how do we then
make sure that you know products that
actually work are the ones getting to us
if there's no regulation whatsoever I'm
slightly playing this short there's
their short term long term issues so one
of the so one of the stories that was
that came out was this Brooklyn man was
apparently hoarding he had started
purchasing millions of masks or
something and was hoarding a lot of them
and we're so concerned about price
gouging that you know if you're an
importer here you don't want to be
guilty of price gouging so you don't you
don't import the masks because of the
price fluctuations and the you know the
feds are gonna come after you as they
did after this Brooklyn man who
basically did nothing wrong except buy a
ton of masks and and hold onto them
that's his property and they you know
they came and they seized it and these
well this is good intention you know we
should businesses or people shouldn't be
trying to make a profit during a crisis
the problem is that the the price when
it when it goes up it's basically an
incentive for producers to produce so we
should be letting the prices fluctuate
right because then we can rush to meet
the demand and it's it's one of those
you know policies or sentiments that's
just has unintuitive in principle but
but it has unintended consequences i I
think you know the
term is we might need to sort of be a
bit more protectionist right I think it
made sense to have export controls to
prevent our current supply of ppes
leaving the country we should have done
that but then in the long term we have
to let the since we have to let the
market you know fluctuate because it's
going to correct itself but you know
people you have facebook did Facebook
prevented a mask advertisements so if
you were because they were concerned
about a hoarding issue so they basically
said all right advertise is now but then
if you Karen you came up with a way to
you know a 3d print a mask
now you money for a Kickstarter so it's
really really shooting ourselves in the
foot so you mentioned the whu-oh of the
World Health Organization and the CDC
the Center for Disease Control it seems
like in the last month the messaging out
of the w-h-o specifically has been just
absolutely all over the place and you
know there's some people that say oh
well they didn't want to push people
into masks sort of for the reasons
you're saying because then regular
people who maybe don't need them are
gonna get all the masks the people who
need them won't have access to them but
have they as an organization really just
kind of flub this thing from the
beginning yeah absolutely the W there's
no question that the w-h-o has you know
basically abandoned its duties in so
many ways I mean you can go all the way
back to December you if you go back to
December 30th that's when China first
reported to the WH o you know that there
were these cases you know clustered
about 41 people that was the first time
reported a day later on the 31st of
January New Year's Eve one basically
said to the WH oh hey
we have heard that this is really
serious and that there's human to human
transmission there's also the 31st of
December and the reason Taiwan her knew
about this was because there were
Taiwanese doctors who had heard from
their mainland colleagues that met
both staff in Wuhan were getting sick so
that's how you know human-to-human
transmission is occurring it's when you
know it's not animal to a person but
person a person it's the patients are
transferring it to to the doctors so
Taiwan reports this and it takes weeks
before you know I think on the 14th of
January you still have that famous tweet
by by the WHL saying there's still no
evidence of human to human transmission
two weeks after Taiwan told them that it
was and and this has been the story of
how they've handled this Dave couch oh
yeah wait let's just let's just pause
there for one sec though let's just
pause there for one sec what is that
like what do you think structurally as
someone that knows about organizations
like this like what happened in those
two weeks did were they intentionally
misleading us did they just completely
drop the ball was there political
pressure was it oh they didn't want to
be too alarmist I mean is it some
combination of all of those things um no
actually the problem is that Taiwan
doesn't have membership to the w-h-o so
China has very successfully muscled
Taiwan out so Taiwan's not recognized as
as a member and and you know for Taiwan
that's very dangerous because you know
if you don't have that connection to the
WTO you are not plugged into this global
health alert system and the global
health alert system is not plugged into
Taiwan so whatever Intel Taiwan had was
completely missed and then the worst
part for Taiwan is that because China
basically muscled them out when all the
other countries were placing travel bans
they were trying to ban you know China
people from China traveling to their
countries they inadvertently banned
Taiwan because Taiwan was seamless part
China which is what China won the whio
drops the ball and then we've
subsequently seen some other strange
tweets and we've seen some some strange
statements by by some of their
representatives Trump was talking about
a band from China back in January
yeah he instituted the ban I think 31st
of January that's when the band actually
happened but at the time the WHI was
saying that they shouldn't do it then
you shouldn't restrict travel to China
and shortly after that also the Chinese
foreign ministry said that they reacted
very badly to Trump's dancing that was
it was racism xenophobic did you the ban
yeah surprise surprise so what do you
make of the fact that now because
hindsight is 20/20 people are saying Oh
Trump didn't do anything
in February everyone knew that this was
gonna happen Trump didn't do anything I
checked yesterday and it turns out that
you know there was a democratic debate
on February I think it's 7th 19th and
25th
none of those debates mentioned anything
about coronavirus oddly yet the media is
now telling us that everybody was
talking about all of this stuff in
February could could he have done more
should he have done more how do you
balance keeping people sane and keeping
the economy open versus a potential
looming threat all of that I mean he did
suggest that he was somewhat distracted
by the impeachment proceedings and for
the whole month of February you did have
our journalist class doing one of two
things saying that this was just you
know kind of the flu just not just
another flu or warning people about you
know that the stigma against Asian
Americans was worse than the virus
itself and so even on the 9th of
February you had the health officials in
New York City saying come out for a
Lunar New Year parade everything's okay
life is normal you know stand up you
know fobian racism so they were still
acting as if understandably a lot of
people missed this you know it's ok so
it lets all just party and mix and and
you know stand in defiance to to this to
this virus so a lot of people miss it
but I read yesterday that on the 29th of
January that Tina Navarro who is the
trade official in terms Kevin
actually wrote a memo warning and saying
that this virus is the real deal and
there's going to be you know at worst
two million deaths at best 100,000 but
we gotta act on it and he proposed
actually a travel ban Trump that he
didn't read the memo but shortly after
on the 31st he actually he actually did
put down the travel ban that's one of
the you know the good things about Trump
is that he didn't really care about that
and this this virus actually really fit
in well with his ideological priors you
know for being conservative on
immigration and being nationalistic in
terms of trade and engagement America
first yeah can you talk a little bit
about just like the inner machinations
of China because right now it's like
just in the last few days we've seen
this thing where you know us cases are
spiking but China is reporting no new
cases no new debts and it's like alright
well just be and then NBC News will
literally make that statement the AP
will make that statement and it's like
well I guess that's sort of reporting
and that you're reporting what China is
reporting but that's not really
independent reporting like can you talk
a little bit about how information can
or can't travel in China you know the
media's job is to be skeptical and
towards that and they are very skeptical
ducotes reporting out of the Trump
administration they're not affording
that same approach to the Chinese
government when of all people who in
should it be skeptical about it should
be numbers that are coming of a very
closed or terian society and you know I
don't think I think China has had a
history of covering up numbers in
general people are very skeptical about
even numbers coming out from their GDP
calculations how they miraculously
always meet exactly six percent target
like exact so they have a history of
hide anything in fact that they had no
qualms suppressing the whistleblower
censoring their their social media why
you know why wouldn't be we not assume
that they're they're covering up their
their numbers so if we can't trust the
numbers that were getting out of China
and sadly we can't really trust our own
media to report on it properly rather
than just regurgitate the numbers how do
we get some sensible information out of
China is there a way to do it that you
can truly trust well you know the CIA
apparently they they submitted
classified for it to the white fellows
bloomberg reported on and they actually
basically said that they were trying to
buy China numbers and we were able to so
you know apart from intelligence
agencies or using some sort of proxy I
think a lot of people saw these videos
that were circulated in social media all
the urns that were you know going to
funeral home and to match up with with
what was reported probably a lot of
these videos once they get posted by
citizen journalists handle it up they
ended up getting taken down for us so
information out of Chinese just Ohio and
I mean unfortunately the only thing that
we have another submitting to the WH oh
yeah can you talk a little bit more just
generally about our relationship with
China China's sort of geopolitical
ambitions and some of the stuff that
they've been doing that has kind of led
us to this really precarious point well
China has you know been on the ascendant
for a long time ever since jongseo King
instituted market reforms they insist on
calling it socialism with Chinese
characteristics and that's really just a
euphemism for moving it in a more
capitalistic direction and it's been
it's been slowly liberalizing
economically and we've you know engage
with China since Richard Nixon and when
in
and and built that relationship and
every president so far has has engaged
with them you know we've sort of
subscribed to this idea that the more
interconnected our markets are and and
the the richer China becomes eventually
it's it's going to liberalize
politically as well that you'll see
freedoms come in you know that the the
average person in China with who's more
affluent to start demanding to have
freedom of speech and you know political
freedoms to vote their that their
leaders out and that just hasn't been
the case at all and if anything China's
become far more powerful than they've
been and they're also growing in their
ambitions so you can see this with their
new military expansions in the South
China Sea the belt and Road initiative
which is basically this infrastructure
project where they sign up all these
countries around the world to build
infrastructure and and and that becomes
like what they called d'etre diplomacy
so they're holding the holding them in a
way that and using that as economic
their economic clout as a way to have
leverage on these countries so the the
Chinese system is really not compatible
with the US as vision for the wall and
also values and I think it's quite clear
that we're becoming strategic rivals and
that in fact there's a good argument to
be made also that China is posing a very
you know possible existential threat to
the United States so are you saying that
for the two plus years that we were
focused on Russia and Ukraine perhaps we
should have been focused elsewhere and
that our eye was off the ball because of
some other nonsense is that what you're
getting at
well you know one of trumps campaign
promises was you know he did he has been
talking about China you seen these clips
like China he does that that's I know
just a federal issue to his his platform
and he's been talking about it for a
long time that we got a very bad trade
deal with them and he was going to come
and fix it the problem with his rhetoric
was that he didn't he didn't
he sort of talked about it a sense of
making America strong again economically
bring that jobs home bringing jobs home
but he didn't talk about it frame it in
terms of this geopolitical struggle
which it is maybe that's because of the
need to you know to still have some
formal relationship and you know in real
politic with China and that would really
offend them but but all you know China
analysts and and you know people who
have been on the ball on this issue have
been have been sounding the alarm for a
while like you know it's look at how
they're able to coerce us even outside
of their own borders to to basically
pair it there orthodoxy when it comes to
you know the whole MBA Hong Kong fiasco
or even you know what what kind of
messages are embedded in our movies so
you can see that they've been trying to
influence from from afar how dangerous
is it that we owe them a lot of money
these are our creditors I'm pretty sure
we're never gonna pay that money back
where does that put us
and a very precarious position but there
are also very strong signs that the
Chinese economy itself is not very
sustainable and that there are issues
that you know it's it's we're just
waiting for this bubble to pop so you
know I had not having being indebted to
China obviously he's giving us a lot of
issues when it comes to leverage and
it's also an embarrassment that the
world's superpower is unable to you know
have that financial hold or Horford's
over a trading partner that's also a
strategic rival but you know I mean
Trump has actually ballooned that that
trade rights and our deficits and since
he came into office and the way this
crisis is going to go that's just going
to get even worse with our economy yeah
and it's not just our economy and our
government that's in bed with China
right I mean we've got you know the NBA
in bed with China we've got universities
in bed with China
you know giant corporations so there's a
there's a multi-layered element to this
right companies - you talked about NBC
just now right NBC's parent company
Comcast actually had it deals in the
billions of dollars to build a minion
land there's like theme parks I mean I
can't think of anything worse like to me
that is literally hell it's getting is
it's being in minion land in Beijing so
they've invested billions in these theme
parks Harry Potter village and you know
you can just imagine when when China
what China did to the NBA after one
general manager said something Kong
where they just canceled you know all
the screenings of the NBA in China that
was how they retaliate it when they
didn't like what won and be manager
tweeted can you imagine you know the
kind of leverage over in the companies
over Hollywood companies because you
know they have business dealings with
them what do you make of the way that
everyone falls into line when it comes
to China so like that NBA thing was
pretty pretty amazing because it was a
random general manager I think for the
Houston Rockets or even maybe it wasn't
even an assistant general manager but a
guy that nobody really was named outside
of that yeah but but nobody really was
he is the general manager right and and
nobody but nobody really knows his name
out of outside of the basketball world
but after that happened the amount of
NBA players LeBron James included who
all sort of bowed to China the same
people who will go on and on and rip
America as a racist evil state and tell
you the Trump is Hitler but but
immediately like all of them the entire
league suddenly was bowing Steve Kerr is
a great example of that you know who
runs around saying how awful
Trump is and everything else but
suddenly when it came to China who got a
quick well the Chinese market is is much
larger than the US market for the NBA
and they've been trying to get into
China for a long time so this has been
you know for them just the biggest
moneymaker not to mention all the
licensing deals NBA stores their shoe
companies
I would say there's actually one player
that's been pretty good on this China
issue and that is Anna's Cantor and
that's because he himself knows what
it's like to live under an authoritarian
and what it's like to stand up to one
Turkish Prime Minister Turkish in this
case yeah so it's it's a shame that
market access own can really modify our
behavior so much to the point where you
know these players who are so quick to
to support CarGurus and you know there
was an NBA boycott of North Carolina
because of the bathroom bills that when
it came to sticking up for our values
for the right of a you know Americans to
just have an opinion about Hong Kong all
of a sudden it just went out the window
that's really sad yeah well by the way
what's the latest in Hong Kong I mean
with everything going on right now we
don't hear anything about Hong Kong
anymore
but they were singing the national
anthem on the streets yeah yeah but
American national anthem
and they were they were waving the flags
and also waving the Union Jack
well the carnal virus obviously has
rendered all protests impossible right
so in that sense it's really neat that
down and also recently well they have
this anti masking law the chief
executive of Hong Kong because they
didn't want their protestors to be able
to mask up but now because everybody
actually has to wear masks to protect
themselves against the corona virus they
had to rewrite the law so that the last
I heard about about Hong Kong but
there's no protests going on now and
it's it's a shame because you know the
it's so moving to see young people on
the streets up against tyranny standing
up against authoritarianism what's your
sense that once we get past this thing
which I assume you believe we'll get
past it how some of the nature of the
relationship with China will change or
at least our discussion about what
they're doing I think in a way America
woken up
to this I shouldn't have taken this
right but we've woken up to the fact
that our industrial supply chain was
located inside an adversary our medical
you know life-saving medical drugs all
the active ingredients are our drugs
were also made in China and and just
people are starting to see and wake up
to this this fact that there is a clash
in value systems between the two
countries and it cannot be it just
couldn't be more clear now it should
have been clear to to you know what what
they did with MBA the Hong Kong issue it
should have been clear but but now it's
really hitting us and I think I mean
I've seen a lot of people now express
the view you know what I don't care
about the cheap stuff anymore
I I rather just pay more and and and be
secure and and and you know have our
supply chains relocated back to America
especially when it comes to the
sensitive stuff not talking about you
know making crayons or something we're
talking about you know the a anything to
do with with tech the higher value add
items yeah so moving away from China a
little bit for our remaining time you're
you're a pretty astute observer of
what's happening in America too and I
and I know you've sort of been on your
own political journey over the last
couple years that I think in some ways
is sort of similar to mine even though
we come obviously from a very different
starting point well what do you make
about what's happening right now
politically in America the way the
conversation is as we're taping this
today we just found out that Bernie
Sanders is dropping out we're holding
this for a little bit do you think Biden
can even do this where are you at with
Trump what's your what's your general
take as the New York editor of Spectator
magazine which is actually one of the
few places of journalism that I don't
have to use air quotes around which is a
really refreshing thing yeah I mean well
I'm really excited that they they gave
me an opportunity and you know I don't
think I've ever they've never tried to
muzzle me or steer me into
into ideological track its just write
whatever you want pitch whatever you
want and so in that sense I do have a
lot of journalistic freedom in terms of
where America is politically this this
cone of ours issue really threw threw a
wrench into it right like we were all
kind of going along and all of a sudden
the news just changed overnight just
completely saturated it and at this
point it's not even clear if if things
are going to get lifted like I'm hearing
conversations now about about voting and
and you know whether we're gonna do this
nail voting at some point I don't know
but suffice to say there is a lot of
dissatisfaction about Joe Biden and I
think I wrote a piece for spectator
about how I don't think the media
actually said at him properly I don't
think they put him through the gauntlet
in a way that they did do to every other
candidate right if you looked at Peabody
shag Bloomberg even Andrew yang you
would find a hit piece on the New York
Times about how they were either racist
in their past or sexist except maybe the
TV show there's something there and and
Biden just wasn't put through the same
pressures and so he's emerged and now
you know the big question is about his
elect well his his mental state does he
have the the not just temperament but
but is he
you know sane enough to actually be the
President of the United States and what
he's coming up against Trump it's it's
the optics it's gonna look it's gonna
look so bad but you know the issue is at
the end of the day the math just didn't
work out for Bernie I know a lot of
people liked him and you know your and
my friend now I guess Joe Rogan really
like Bernie too but I see a lot of
people kind of echoing what he said
which is you know Bernie or bust and
it's creating such a such a big rift I
don't know I don't know how that's gonna
get result yeah
so as someone that's now in the media
what do you make of a media these days
because I'm sort of like man there you
know a lot of us have been screaming
the media for a while and I think maybe
now that so many people are trapped at
home and they're forced online more I
think it's becoming more and more
obvious to people that maybe weren't
taking the temperature so that if you
were watching CNN with their selectively
edited Trump quotes and normally you
wouldn't pay that much attention to it
now you're stuck at home online and
you're seeing full quotes be shared by
other people where they stop his
sentence right after he says but this
thought that that I do you sense that
the media has just gone completely crazy
is there a way to get them to come back
I mean can the New York Times reel it
back in can CNN really back in or have
they just chosen a model that they think
is best which is well I guess lie
because that's what your base wants that
something something like that I saw that
CBS was using clip of you know video
clips of Italy to when they were talking
about the NARC situation and and that is
just it's gaslighting Italian how it's
really literally showing Italian
hospitals it's it does throat the public
trust I mean I think we have to separate
between the opinion pieces and the
actual reporting you know the
International Bureau these big
organizations right like the New York
Times they do excellent reporting when
it comes to the Middle East I mean even
on China right what which recently
expelled Wall Street Journal Washington
Post and The New York Times journalists
that were there for decades expelled out
of Beijing and now we don't have eyes on
there you have volcanion pieces and
activist journalist that's really where
we're you know I think the problem is
and apart from just you know the
business model issue which which I think
we haven't really solved yet you kind of
you know going you've actually kind of
built a platform to solve it but that is
one of the reasons why that you know
this this world of activism journalism
exists it's it's its clickbait ii and
the incentives that were worth that kind
of journalism is still there i I don't
know how how to solve this it's just
apart from changing this and rewiring
the whole incentive structure you know
or just having what we do have now this
fragmentation of media
is actually probably a good thing I know
we you know we used to say that it was a
bad thing but but the fact that there is
conservative media I mean frankly Tucker
Carlson I'm so impressed with him like
the coverage that he has done since this
current started and actually before that
he was doing really good stuff also in
China but it's it's important more than
ever that we do have these voices
because it puts the pressure I had a
tweet about this the other day so you
there was clip where a Hong Kong
journalist handed the and the WH are
very senior official and asked him about
Taiwan and he just backtracked it was
like such a shameful you know tried to
weasel out of the conversation and it
looked really bad and for the first four
hours the only media that reported on it
was the blaze was Fox News was PJ media
was all the so-called right-wing but if
it didn't get picked up by them the
story would have never bubbled up and by
by picking up on it they're forcing you
know the mainstream media
it's a respond to log that and it kind
of gets into the public consciousness in
a way that imagine if they didn't exist
it just wouldn't have so it's important
it is important that we have you know
competing interest and at least there's
a chance that the truth gets out yeah
and I know for you as I think someone
that you still consider yourself a good
decent liberal it's kind of funny that
you have all these allies on the right
and you have to give props to
conservative media I suppose to get
these stories out there unfortunately we
we don't have any more time but in
quickly in 30 seconds and then next time
we're obviously going to do this in
person and it will be great to see you
again what just give me like your sense
of like sort of when we get out of this
and and are we gonna be okay on the
other side of this thing I think we're
gonna have to learn how to live with it
as long as there's no vaccine as long as
anti viral you know whatever antiviral
treatments are still not developed we're
gonna have to learn how to live the
virus and there's going to be waves so
you know we're in mitigation stage now
and and I hope I hope our curve start a
flat in California is doing a very good
job with it so we'll see but there's
things are real
lining and lives are changing alright
Melissa that was great seeing even
though we had to do this through the
Skype machine we will do this in person
next time and good seeing you as always
Cameron we're obviously in some
unchartered territory with coronavirus
and our plan here is to help you make as
much sense of the situation and a non
alarmist fashion as possible if you're
looking for reliable information from
experts on the front lines of the
pandemic check out our coronavirus
playlist which will keep adding updates
too right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe